coué bienvenue à paroles autochtone et
si c'est melissa maulin depuis sept
semaines veut répondre à la question de
audrey qui me demandent que pensez-vous
des intervenants blanc dans les
communautés autochtones exemple dpj
services sociaux et enseignement audrey
devant une opinion personnelle avec
multiples parce que je pense que les
intervenants qu'ils soient blancs qu'ils
soient liés l'immigration où qu'ils
soient autochtones sont extrêmement
nécessaire parce qu'on a besoin de
services dans les communautés cependant
il faut faire très attention de ne pas
arriver avec des idées préconçues sur
les communautés ce qui a vraiment pu
être très néfaste dans les communautés
c'est d'arriver avec ce qu'on appelle la
mentalité du sauveur on va les sauver on
va les aider mais sans jamais consulter
les communautés sans jamais s'intéresser
non plus à la culture de fond à
l'histoire familiale et à la façon de
faire dans les communautés présentement
beaucoup de services de la dpj sont
repris par les communautés
donc ça montre que ces services leçons
nécessaires simplement il faut aussi les
rampes culturellement sécuritaire
beaucoup de personnes qui vont venir à
intervenir que ce soit des médecins ou
que ce soit des infirmiers ou où des
policiers vont avoir des contacts
extrêmement intime avec des familles
d'origine autochtone que ce soit d'une
nation à l'autre sont très différentes
d'une nation à l'autre c'est très
différent et surtout ils arrivent avec
leur propre appréhension leur propre
interprétation de ce qu'est la culture
des premières nations et des fois même
avec leurs propres à priori
souvent parce qu'ils ont ce qu'on
remarque c'est que ceux qui s'intègrent
bien la vie communautaire vont rester là
pendant plusieurs années et ce avec qui
ça fonctionne pas ce centre est isolé et
repartent au bout d'un an
donc il ya quand même une nécessité de
connaître l'histoire de fond des
communautés faites moi peu importe
l'origine du travailleur ou
d'intervenant temps qu'il est formé et
qu'il est sensibilisé aux questions et
aux enjeux autochtones je pense que
c'est nécessaire
jusqu'au jour où on l'espère on n'aura
plus besoin de ses services le autant
dans nos communautés
alors en espérant avoir bien répondu à
la question
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos et
ils déposent surtout à nous envoyer des
questions à paroles autochtone souhaite
une belle semaine